The DIY aspects of skateboarding started from day one.
So I entered a competition for a three-month lease on a piece of land in East London.
After I won the project,...
...I suddenly realized I had no budget and only four weeks to build it.
I threw away a job in engineering and started all again to have a go at this.
Welcome to Frontside.
We've got the main sort of street course on this left here.
The white boards are from a local art exhibition.
The ply we managed to get from McGrath's around the corner.
Standing in the park now watching it well-used is a massive buzz.
I love the vibes here.
This is where we spend most of our days at.
We think this place is amazing considering it's all built by hand and stuff.
Yeah, the skate park's only temporary.
I just hope that some of the things the kids have learned...
...and some of the memories they've got are a little bit more permanent.